why do you feel that it's okay now to
have unlikable characters versus Leave
It to Beaver a warm I Love Lucy is it
just a sign of the times have changed
where that whole nuclear family is
really no longer in any sense or what is
it that we're more willing to look at
these unlikable characters and even root
for them well the first reason is what
you just mentioned which is the classic
nuclear family no longer exists or it's
it's greatly diminished from what it was
and this of course is the whole
foundation for modern family which is
revolutionary in the sense that it's
taking the family sitcom and it's
modernizing it by creating a family
which is made up of three variations to
the nuclear family
each is a different version of it we
have the the older guy marrying the you
know that the the younger woman with the
kid right we have the the two gay guys
with their family and the little kid and
then we have what looks like a nuclear
family but it's not with the classic
father knows best father dominated
nuclear family it's a mother dominate
it's a female dominated family so and
then what they do is they take these
three versions of family and put them
together as one family and all of the
all of the episodes are tracking these
three different families ultimately
coming together as one family at the end
so that's one reason why the audience
can't appreciate these unlikable
characters because what they see as
reality is these these all different
versions of who people can be and how
they can relate to each other in a
family but the other reason is that the
audience's understanding of story has
changed and grown because they realize
unlikable characters are
much more interesting and it is because
of their character flaws that we like
them more not in spite of those flaws
and this indicates an understanding by
the audience of of of media of story
their their story knowledge is so much
higher now than it was back in the 50s
and 60s when the traditional sitcom
stories and families were shown so it's
it it really represent now in order to
catch the audience you have to do much
more with your character with your
initial character creation than you had
to do in the past what a Seinfeld I
think they would work certainly a Mary
Tyler Moore would have to be change in
the sense that it's fundamental feature
the fact that she was you know you're
gonna make it after all one of the
original women's liberation shows done
in a comic version that that kind of
pioneering woman it's not a pioneer
anymore we've now had that for many
years but still the the key to that show
was the brilliance of the writing though
how the characters were created the
character opposition's you know this is
all the stuff that the nuts and bolts of
how a show is created that I talk about
at my TV class which is which is it's
all about it's not just about creating
individual characters it's how you
relate them how you create a web of
characters because again this is how
we're gonna generate a show for five
years it's the interaction between these
characters it's not doesn't come from
outside characters that we bring in
every week new it's how the characters
we know and love how they play off each
other and we have to create a comic
opposition that can be sustained for
five years that's really hard to do but
on that show it was brilliant
looking to convey the comic characters
and the character whether brilliant
now similarly a Seinfeld the character
opposition's if you look at how it was
created with those four central
characters and this is a crucial concept
in both sitcom and TV drama the
foundation of four and this is this is
one of the techniques for again
generating story over multiple years but
again Seinfeld brilliantly created in
both the character and the plot and I
believe that that's what audiences most
relate to now even at the time
Seinfeld almost didn't make it because
he was so revolutionary and it was so
different compared to what anybody had
seen before and it was also instead of
talking down to the audience it was very
advanced in terms of how quick it was
the wit the wordplay and so on and that
were also won against conventional
wisdom so but but the fact that this the
simple quality of the comedy writing was
so great I believe that it would be
still successful today although it might
have to be on cable like a Curb Your
Enthusiasm because that is essentially
Seinfeld it's it's all of the the the
key characteristics of Seinfeld but in a
slightly different form but of course
it's on cable
you